そうすることで 一般の人々から見れば
この人何者かと 頭おかしいではないかと思うかもしれません
その人にも普通の世間に戻って行動することはできなくなっちゃう
それ 仏教の世界から見ればこういうふうになります
例えば禅定を作るとき
土の色をとって瞑想する一つのシステムありますね
それはアビダンマ それから出ます
アビダンマという瞑想対象にする
土の色の対象を取って瞑想しちゃうと
どんどんイメージがというか
この何て言いますか 頭の中をそれで見えるようになって
どんどん全部そういう風に見られるようになってしまっちゃうんです
それでこの対象は巨大化するという訓練するんです
見えるものはほんの小さく見え始めちゃいますから
それは大きく大きく大きく見えるようにすると
もしその人はそのままで
大体隠れてやるのはそういうわけなんで
瞑想は壊れるんだから隠れてやるんです
で その時はその人に壁見たっても土色に見える
水を見ても土色に見えてしまう
人を見たっても人を見えない
土色に見えてしまう それから自分の瞑想対象ばっかし見えるようになっちゃったら
人間がいても全然人間見えなくなっちゃう
全部平らになっている
土色の一つの何て言いますか
大きな布を拭いたような感じで見えちゃうんです
実際にこちら人がいるのに
その人に見えなくなっちゃう
ですから人が喋ったっても
その人はもう何も聞こえないというか
もう気にしないというか
という状態になるんです
それも別におかしい状態ではなくて
その禅定ではなくて 瞑想によってそうなってしまう
で その場合は仏教でいうのは禅定できるまで気をつけなさいということ
禅定できたらまたこの素寂静自在やりますから
で その人にご飯持っていって
これ食べてくださいと言っても
その人にとってはご飯見えないんです
土しか見えないので だから食べられなくなる可能性もあります
で そういうことで このウッターナワシっていうのは禅定に入ってすぐ禅定状態から抜ける
出る 出てすぐ普通の心に戻る
ものすごい高い次元からサッと普通の次元に戻ることを訓練する
禅定の世界で自分にはそのものしか見えなかったし
一体感もあります 自分も消えていたんだけど
それ決まった時間終わったらすぐもう目を覚めたら普通に人間と人間は人間として見られる
物は物として見られるような
この欲界世間に心を急にレベルダウンすることを訓練する
そうしなきゃ もうちょっとその人は特別な人生
それからやらなくちゃいけないんですね
仏教の世界では 瞑想する人々は必ずこれはやるんですね
ですから 瞑想する時は瞑想の世界
終わったら何のことなく普通の世界にいる
普通の人間の価値判断の中で
何のことなくそれに従って生活できるし
また瞑想しようと思ったら
すぐその世界に入って
その高次元の心のレベルを体験もする
ですから サマーディに入ることも上手になるだけではなくて
サマーディに長い時間いられることも上手
それでも必要であるし
それからサマーディからパッと出て普通の心を作ることも訓練しなくちゃいけない
それも心の 例えば我々は誰か何かショックを受けちゃったら
そのショックから抜けるためにはもう時間がかかるでしょうに
1ヶ月間とか 1年  2年とかね
あるいは一生そのショックから抜けられないという精神的な弱みっていうのは
どんな人間にもあります
何か頭に引っかかったらなかなか抜けられない
例えばこういう講義聞こうと来ても
もし来る前に何か気になることがあったならば
出会ったならば それも頭から抜けられなくて
もう講義は聞いても聞いてない状態になってしまっちゃうとか
そういうのは心の普通の働きなんです
それを直せなくちゃいけない
それを直すために この素寂静自在ということを訓練する
で それできたらまたもう一回一番目やるんですね
その時は言葉違います
[背景音楽]パッチャヴェッカラ・ヴァシットという
パッチャヴェッカラっていうのは 1番目とほとんど同じなんです
パッチャヴェッカラっていうのは観察なんですね
1番目の観察は禅定に入ってからすぐするんです
私は何を得たらと  5番目のパッチャヴェッカラっていうのは
禅定をよく訓練できたところで
禅定っていうのはいかなるものかと観察するながら
この禅定の弱点 弱いところ
そういうものにも心を持っていくんですね
これこそ最終解脱ですかとかとかね
本当にこれは最終解脱ですかとか
そうするとこの禅定の弱みが見えてくるんです
徹底的に観察しないと禅定の弱みは見えてこないんです
1番目の場合は何を何を体験したかということで
弱みまで見る暇がないんです
どんどん同じ禅定に何回何回も入って入って経験を得たところで
いろいろ弱みがあるということは見えてきます
それでもう禅定に対するあの強力なあの執着
これこそすごいことを得たんだという
あの執着 あの欲が消えるんです
この禅定に対する欲はパーリ語で欲という言葉を使わない
欲はローバですから その言葉を使わないでこの違う言葉を使うんです
ニカンティという言葉を使っているんです
ニカンティの意味も欲望なんです
欲求なんです だから結局人間っていうのは普通の世界である欲を捨てるんです
捨てて瞑想するんですが
もし超越した超越した何か精神的な経験を得たら
それはありがたいと それをもうしがみついちゃうんですね
仏教から見ればそれも欲ですよと
でも本人はそれを欲と認めたくない
認めたくないんだから
その禅定を得た人がこの禅定についてものすごい観察して
いろいろ弱みをわかって
ああ大したことないんだと
これも と その欲を捨てる
その欲を捨てられたところで
次の2番目の禅定を作ることができるんです
もっとレベル高い禅定を作ろうではないかと
例えば第1禅定の場合はヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラという 2つの特色があるんですね
ヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラというのは瞋恚と
書きますけどね 一つ この言葉で考えることなんですね
言葉なくなくなったら
あの対象がもう消えてしまうんです
ずっと 例えば土だったらパーリ語でパタリーパタリーと瞑想するんです
頭の中で言葉を使うんです
そのパタリーパタリーという言葉の回転なければ
あの対象代わりに他の雑念が入ったりして崩れちゃうんですね
それ第一禅定を得た人が
やっぱりこの言葉でずっと言葉を回転させないと得られないものだと
禅定っていうのは弱いものだと
もし強い禅定だったら
言葉回転させなくても得られるはずだよ
はずだよと思って さらに言葉回転させないで禅定を得られるように努力すると
第二番目の禅定が生まれるんです
ですから 第二番目の禅定を得るためには
五番目の慈才を訓練しなくちゃいけない
いわゆるこういうのは
この単なる分析というよりは確実に必要なものなんです
第一番目の禅定を得て満足した人は
どんな理由があっても第二禅定は得られないんですね
私は満足しているんだと
これで 人間の世界でもそうでしょうね
何かに満足しちゃったらそれ以上行かないんだから
だから一般的には諦めるのは早い人はあまり褒められませんだけど
やっぱり早く諦めた方が
もう何かこれ面白いとやり始めたって
もうすぐ諦めた人が他のことを次にやっちゃうんですね
それに凝った人は死ぬまでそればっかりやってるんだから
だから禅定を作ってもこういう訓練して
十慈才になって諦めちゃう
それについて諦めることでこの未完気が消える
欲が消えてもっと頑張ろうと出てくるんですね
で この五つのセットで
仏教では瞑想する人々はね
おかしくならないようにすごく守っているんです
ヴィパッサナーではそういうのは全部このワンパックにしているんです
だから随分優れてる瞑想って呼んで
サマーディの場合はワンパックじゃないんです
別々に訓練しなくちゃいけない
ですから ヴィパッサナー瞑想して
わずかでも心がおかしくなったという人は一人もいない
もともと心弱い人にとっては
ヴィパッサナー瞑想というのはあまりにも強力で
もう忍耐できないんです
ですから 心弱い人はやらない方がいい
精神的な弱い人とかね
で すごい精神的に強くて
ものすごい知識があって
物事を自分で判断したい
自分で決めたいという風な
この立派な性格の人々にはヴィパッサナー瞑想は合うんです
もともと弱くて弱くて
何かにすがりたいとか
誰かに救ってほしいとかね
そういうふうな弱い人には難しいんです
で それだけヴィパッサナーの問題ですけど
でもこういうパンチャシーっていうのは
一応もう一つにしてセットにして
そうなるようになってるんです
ですから ヴィパッサナーでは頭おかしくなることはないんです
サマーディ瞑想では気をつけないと
まあどうなることかよくわからないんです
だからこの一時的にそういうサマーディみたいな神秘体験というんですね
一般宗教用語で 神秘体験あった人々は
後で社会をおかしくしたり
犯罪をしたり みんなに迷惑をかけたりするということは
まあ昔もありましたし
じゃあそういう人々はせっかく自分たちがサマーディを作ったのに
この神秘体験というものはね
仏教ではサマーディだから
作ったのに それによって梵天に生まれ変われる可能性もあったのに
それも壊れてしまって
またコーマになって自分が経験を得たんだと
だからもう自分を認めないとは殺してもいいやとかね
ただの普通の悪人より悪人になってしまっちゃうんです
だからもうそういう人々は
たとえお釈迦様にしたっても
もうどうすることもできないんです
例えばお釈迦様出てきたって聞いてくれないんだから
話をね ですからサマーディはちゃんとした勉強した上で
あるいはちゃんとした指導者の指導があった上でやるもんやった方がよろしいし
で この判断しますからね
解釈しますから 人間っていうのは
それ解釈癖をやめるためには
ものすごいもう怖い指導者のそばでやるか自分であるいはすべての解釈をやめるか
どっちかなんです  [笑い]じゃあそれからこの話に戻ります
なんかおかしくなった
消すじゃなくて汚すということになったんです
なんでそうなるんでしょうか
手形も入ってるんです
私じゃないみたい で 一番目に一番初め
自分の人生の禅定に入る時は一回しか安心心が生まれません
禅定の心は生まれません
そこで二回目 三回目やっちゃうと
こちらで説明したように
この心がもういくらかいくらかサマーディ心が伸ばすことはできるんです
例えばこの指を鳴らすぐらいの時間
禅定に入っていられることができたというと
その人の心にはたくさんサマーディサマーディサマーディ心がたくさん生まれるんですね
そうすると あの職業心七つという法則は変わっちゃうんですね
七つのところじゃなくて
百二百生まれる可能性もあります
一つのチッタ・ヴィーティの中で
チッタ・ヴィーティは一応職業心七つでセットカットしているんですね
それで禅定を作る場合はもっと短くなっちゃうんです
禅定に二 三回 四回 五回
六回入るように訓練しちゃうと
短くなるんじゃなくて
ものすごい長いチッタ・ヴィーティが生まれてきちゃう
それはもうジャーナニウムですね
あの職業心の法則なんですね
それからこの出世間の場合は
いわゆるヴィパッサナー瞑想して悟る場合は
職業心のまた言葉変わっちゃうんですね
パリカンマ ウパチャーラ
それからアヌローマ それからゴートラブ
それは同じ名前で パリカンマっていうのは準備する心
禅定を作るために いわゆる悟りの
例えば預流果になるための準備
ウパチャーラっていうのは預流果になったぐらいの状態に何か似てくる
似てくる アヌローマっていうのは預流果になった人の心とほとんど似ている状態になると
それからゴートラブということは
ゴートラブっていうのは
まあそれから次の心 次元が飛び出すということです
ゴートラブの心生まれた瞬間で道心が生まれるんですね
夜の場合は夜道心が生まれるんです
夜道心っていうのはもう一人の人に一回しか生まれません
というのは 夜道心というのは
この ある煩悩を完全に絶してしまうんですね
いわゆる煩悩三つが書いてますけどね
あの有身見と疑と戒禁取という三つですね
その三つの煩悩をもう二度と生まれないようになくなっちゃうんです
智慧で 智慧の刃物なんです
サマーディではなくならないんです
サマーディからもう欲が生まれるかもしれませんだけど
サマーディから結局欲が生まれるんです
悪いものじゃないんだけど
もう 違う欲が 例えばずっともう海苔とご飯だけ食べてた人に
もうチキンとご飯食べさせちゃったら
やっぱりあれこちらの方が美味しいとなるだけのそれからそれ食べたくなっちゃうんですね
ですから欲が変わるんです
ちょっとレベル高い欲に
それはサマーディだけやっちゃうとそんなことで
で 智慧使っちゃうとサマーディの力より智慧の力の方が多い
強いんだからもう全部カットするんですね
ですからこの切断する
煩悩を切断しちゃったんだだからもう二度と生まれませんね
その煩悩は ですから 煩悩を切断するという意味でマッガチッタというんです
道心というんです だから二回目は生まれません
一回死ん殺した人をまた殺しますということは不可能ですから
ですから 一旦なくした煩悩はもうなくしちゃったんだから
もう生まれません そういうことで
道心は一回だけ 次の心はカ心というんです
いわゆる煩悩をなくしたという結果なんですね
で カ心はヨルドーの場合
ヨルドーとヨルカですね
二つぐらい生まれる可能性はあります
一つの場合もあるし 二つの場合もあるし
二つぐらい生まれて またウボン心に心がいっちゃうんです
で そこでどれぐらい色業心生まれるかというと
パリカーマ ウパチャーラ
アヌローマ ゴートラブ
マッガ ファラ ファラ二つ入ったら七つになります
カは一つになっちゃったら六つになります
次に まあ何て言いますか
ウボン心になる その時もパンチャヴァーシーやらなくちゃいけないんです
パンチャヴァーシーなくてもアワッジャは必要なんです
一番目は アワッジャって
えーと インテンジサイ
自分にどうなったんですかということを観察しなくちゃいけない
その時は消えた煩悩を観察する
それでさらにヴィパッサナー瞑想しながら
できればまた一回ぐらいでもこのヨルカに入っても構いません
また瞑想しちゃうとヨル道心が生まれません
あのゴートラブのチッタの次にカ心が急に生まれるんです
もう煩悩をなくなっているんだから道心は生まれません
カ心は二つ三つぐらい生まれちゃう
ヨルカ心は また入ってみると
それでヨルカになった人がいろいろ後で自分の状態を観察すると
ああ 私は有身見もないんだ
疑もないんだ 戒禁取もないんだとわかるんです
わかるんだけど やっぱり怒りがあるんだ
欲があるんだとかね 自分の状態ではそういう欠点も見えてくるんですね
それはアワッジャ・ヴァーシーですね
五番目の観察ヴァーシーな
観察ジサイなんです そうすると
これでは足りませんと
もっと上の方にチャレンジしなくちゃいけないんだと
となっちゃうんです それでヴィパッサナーの場合
私は言ったんだから この五つセットになってるんだと
このパンチャヴァーシーはセットになってるんだだと言ったんだから
ヴィパッサナー瞑想する人にとってはいつでも自分の弱点が見えているはずなんです
自分がすごいんだとかね
よくやったぞと思っちゃったら
どこかでおかしいんです
その人は道は間違ってるんです
ちゃんとヴィパッサナーの方で行っちゃうと
ずっと自分の弱いところ
自分の未熟なところっていうのは
ずっと心の中でもううろうろうろうろそこら辺にいるんです
たとえ悟りの心が生まれても
すぐなんか自分の未熟さ
これで終わりかと なんか納得いかないんだと
それでも何かまだあるんではないかと
すぐ頭に来るんです 頭に来るっていうのは
頭に浮かぶんです ですから絶対狂わないんです
正しくヴィパッサナーやる人は
最初からみんなにもうやってみせるぞとかね
偉くなってやるぞという気持ちで瞑想を始めたら
それはヴィパッサナーにはなりませんからね
ただご苦労さんだけですけどね
自我を捨てる目的でやらなくちゃいけないんですね
で ですからこのパンチャ・ヴァーサっていうのは
まあやっぱりすごい素晴らしくこの空いてるんです
ヴィパッサナーだけでは
そういう風にこの禅定において
この即行心の数がいろいろ変化するんです
それだけはこちらで言ってることはね
次に言いたいのは このニローダ・サマーパッティということ
このチャートがありますから
2ページにありますね
ニローダ・サマーパッティ
滅尽定というのは で この滅尽定っていうのは
これは特別なことなんです
それは得ることはできるのは
このすべてのサマーディ瞑想を完成している人
まず いわゆる色界の 第4番目の禅定と無色界の 第4番目まで
色界・無色界禅定は全てもう合格している
その上 ヴィパッサナー瞑想して
最低不還果ぐらいでもなってなきゃ難しいんです
で 一般的に仏教というのは不還果にも難しいと
これは阿羅漢果になってないと
この滅尽定に入ることは難しいんです
不還果にも可能ですよとは言ってますけど
入ったケースは一つも残ってないんです
経典の中でもないし 注釈書にもない
あるのは全部阿羅漢の方々
聖者たちだけ 滅尽定に入ってましたと
このどのようにその瞑想するかというと
この阿羅漢になった聖者が
じゃあこれから滅尽定に入るということを決めて
普通のサマーディ瞑想を続けていくんです
サマーディ瞑想を第一禅定からどんどんどんどんレベルアップして無色界に行っちゃうんです
無色界というのは全く言葉で説明できない
全く違う瞑想の世界なんですね
何の形もない ただ心だけ働く世界で
そこで四番目は非想非想非想非想定と言うんですね
この非想非非想定という八番目のサマーディ
色界・無色界の四番目
サマーディとしていえば八番目のサマーディ
最高なサマーディ その時は自分の心が在るかないかというぐらいにも
自分にもう本人には心が働くかないか
なんかそこまで心の働きが弱くなるんです
弱くというか 波がものすごい小さくなるんです
普通我々はものすごいショックを受けたりとか
すごい荒波ですね 心っていうのは
それなくて ただ心が消滅しているだけ
もう何も波もない いわゆる心象っていうのは全部統一されちゃって
もうもう何も機能しなくなっちゃうんです
それ以上は心は成長することはできない
そこでこの滅尽定が じゃなくて非想非想非想非想定が
の心がサマーディが回か二つぐらいサマーディ心が生まれて
次に心が完全にストップするんです
ですから阿羅漢になった人に限るんです
それは心を完全にストップすること
この流れがね ずっと流れる心がもう絶対ストップできない
一つの心消えると次の心が生まれる
それはもう決まってて
もうエネルギーですから
もう消えるということはありえないんです
でも心の場合は阿羅漢になった人が
もし非想非想非想非想定という禅定までサマーディも訓練しているならば
自分の心を綺麗にストップ
ですから ここら辺では何の物理学も科学も効かない
完全にストップになるわけじゃないんだというのは
普通の俗世間の物理学
科学だから 心には完全にストップできるんです
とにかく で 完全にストップになってどれぐらいの時間経つかというと
それはまあ結構時間いられるんです
で まあ経典にいろいろストーリー
物語ありますからね ストーリーから言うと
大体一週間いられるんだと
一週間以上はできないんだと
いわゆる我々の俗的な知識で言えば
一週間死んでいる 本当に死んでいると
今普通の人には死ぬこと不可能です
死んじゃったらどこかに生まれるんだから
心は止まりませんから
体が死んでも 我々麻酔なんかかけちゃっても心は動いてるんだから
寝ても心は動いてるんだから止まりません
だから本当に一週間も死んでいるんです
だから死ぬんだから その瞬間で
この物質的な この体 機械
それもストップするんです
我々の細胞はストップしないでしょ
顕微鏡で見るとかなり激しく動いてるんだから
物質もずっと顕微鏡で見ちゃうと
電子顕微鏡で見るとかなり変化して動いているってことは見えるんですね
今のね 電子顕微鏡で原子まで見られるんだから
原子ほど落ち着きのないものは何もないんですね
見たところで一つ一個一個
あれは直接は見えませんだけど
原子の形をこのコンピューターでプロセスして
このモニターで作り出しますけど
その作り出す映像もものすごく揺れてるんですね
だから私たちが喋っちゃったら
その波動を吸って その原子がものすごい混乱しちゃって
だからどんなものでも我々の音によって変化するんです
だからマイクロ波なんか存在しているでしょうね
私が喋るたびに そちらの分子が変化して
全く変化して新しい分子が作っちゃう
電気信号に入れ替えちゃって
音を通してまた記録したりする
ですから物質さえ止まらないんです
で そのメス尋常になっちゃったら
物質 物質の働きもストップするんです
それはですからもう科学ではありえないこと
科学正しいか お釈迦様正しいかで
そこで判断するしか方法ないんです
で 正しい科学で我々何をやってくれてるんですかというと
何もやってくれてないでしょうに
心育てることやらね ちょっとすぐ怒りっぽい人の怒りが抑えることぐらい科学できますかね
できないでしょうに そういうぐらい弱い科学言ってることはね
完全正しいわけじゃないし
で でも科学的に言えば
例えばこの分子がしっかりと組み立てるとすごい硬いものができちゃうんですね
例えばダイヤの場合は
このカーボンの分子がすごい丁寧に揃ってるんです
丁寧に揃ってるんだから
間の穴とかそれほどないんです
分子と分子の間の だからダイヤってのは一番硬いと
硬いんだけど 金槌で言っちゃったらすぐバラバラ壊れちゃいますけどね
超硬いと言うんですね
もしその分子も動かないようになったら
原子もその電子も遺伝子も止まっちゃったら
世界で一番硬いものができるはずなんです
核の周りに電子が動いてるでしょうに
動いてるこっちは波動しているんだからね
そういうものはお互いにちょっと何か糊みたいにちょっと引っ張られて
もう一つの分子ができちゃうし
分子分子お互いに引っ張られてものは出ますけど
間すごい穴があるんですね
それで弱いんですからね
ものっていうのは もしそういう電子自体も核そのものもストップになったらどうなるかというと
それ壊すことは誰にも不可能なんです
どんな原子爆弾を落としても壊れません
なぜならそこ止まってるんだから
そういうことでメス尋常に入ったら
その人の体には何もすることは誰にもできないんです
その人の頭の上に原子爆弾爆発しちゃっても何も変化はないぐらい体も変わっちゃう
ですから それだけこのメス尋常ということだけ
ものすごい特別な阿羅漢になった人にもできませんし
阿羅漢になっただけでもできませんし
サマーディ瞑想も究極的に成長していないとできないんです
ですから お釈迦様はもう科学的に物事を考えたとか
もう勝手に仮定するならば
それは仏教の偉大なるさを証明するために使っているものなんです
できればやってみろと
ここまで だからもう真実を仰ったんだから
もう物質の働きも心の働きもありのものを説明したんだから
じゃあ変化してみせるんですね
止まって見せるんです
物質は心で動いているんだと
心は止まっちゃったら物質も止まるはずなんです
止まるんです それで実践してね
実行してみせたらもう
だからストーリーあるんです
あるお坊さんがね もうどこかで人がいないところで
まあ禅定 滅尽定に入っていきましたと
で 夜泥棒のグループが来て
まあ夜森の中だから何も見えない
なんかこの小さなこの半分カットしている木が
あれ何といいますかね
木をカットしたら残り物に切り株
切り株があるという こっち何か切り株があるんじゃないかなと
切り株か石が一つあるかなではないかなと思って
自分持ってきたこの盗んでいたものを全部そのお坊さん阿羅漢の体の中にあっちこっち上に上に入れて乗せたんだと
乗せて 朝は全部お互いに品物を分けて帰ろうと
と見たところで それ切り株でも石でもなくて人なんですね
泥棒たちがもうすごい怖くなっちゃった
これ大変だ バレちゃったんだ
この人この場で殺さなくちゃいけないんだ
行ってあっちこっちからまだずっと目を閉じて動かないでいるんだから
で いろんな木やら枝やら持ってきて
大きなもう大きな何といいますか
こう固めて火をつけて帰っちゃったんです
全部火をもう枝は全部燃えて燃えて燃えて燃えて
もう灰になってなっちゃうんです
でもそのお坊さんがそのままいるんです
そして自分の週間終わったところで
何のことなくそこから立ち上がって帰ったんだと
自分でも知らない 何が起きたかと
自分の体にも何の変化もない
ということを言うために
そういうストーリー書いてますけど
とにかくこの滅尽定の一番珍しいことは
この そういう物質的な変化っていうのは別にどうでもいいことなんですけど
この心が止まることなんですね
そこでまあ一日間 あるいは一時間でも
まあ一秒でも心止まるとものすごい楽なんです
で それから次にどんな心が現れるかというと
順番的に一番高い心が現れる
非想非非想触生の心が現れる
現れて それから有分身になって
それから順番に瞑想から下っていくんですね
これもジャナのニヤマに入る一つのことで
この場合は時間はものすごい長い長い
一つのチッタ・ヴィッティには一週間かかっちゃう
普通だったら指を鳴らす時でもチッタ・ヴィッティがもう一億ぐらい起こりますけど
この場合は一週間ぐらいかかっちゃう
一つのチッタ・ヴィッティ終わるために
最後にこの非想非想触生という心が生まれて
それから有分身になって
次に瞑想は順番に下りるんです
急に普通の心に来るんではなくて
次に アキンチャニャーヤタナ
アヴィニャーナンチャヤタナ
この色無色定に戻って
それから空無色定 これからなんとかなんとかそういうアーカサナンチャヤ
それから番目 番目 番目
一番目の禅定になって
それから普通の心に戻るんです
順番に えーと まあこの即行心の法則として
まあそれからあるのはこのこのチャートで見ると分かりますけど
ダンダーヴィンニャ キッパーヴィンニャの差はなんですかとかね
それは 説明したと思いますけど
このダンダーヴィンニャっていうのはゆっくり悟る人ですね
彼らにはやっぱり最後の心にもパリカンの心が生まれちゃうんです
準備の心が一つ入っちゃうんですね
それでほんのちょっと遅くなるんです
その分即行心は一つ増えるんです
それだけの差 アヴィンニャー・ヴィッティというのは迅速のチッタ・ヴィッティですね
迅速作る場合は禅定の心が一つです
それですぐに有分身に落ちるんです
まあそれぐらいでそのポイントは終わります
次にあるところはね そんなに難しいところでもないし
別にきめ細かく説明しなくてもいいところですと思いますが
この何て言いましたっけ
プッガラ・ビヘダ